i am so excited her award-winning
groundbreaking podcast dying for sex has
been downloaded 10 million times and
counting i know
and now she hosts the brand new podcast
call me curious that features uh hot
topics and explores mysteries out in the
world she also happens to co-host a
podcast called straight talk with ross
matthews hello hi please welcome nikki
boyer
i'm so excited
thank you for having me i love you both
my two best girls here are right at the
same time i think we're gonna be both at
your wedding as well so you guys know
drew barrymore is my flower girl at the
wedding
and
nikki is officiating the wedding
i am so honored i didn't even told
anybody i'm not very excited because i
was with nikki when i met my fiance
welly how cute is that i know we were on
the rooftop of this beautiful hotel and
i spotted him in the corner and i was
like
what's going on over there and then
after you met him you had a brief moment
and i looked at ross and i said you just
met your husband
she did right high five isn't that so
great like i had a feeling i knew it we
met back in what 2007 i think yeah this
is at the golden globes this is the day
i met nikki and she wrapped her leg
around me do you see that my kind of
girl yeah
i didn't give him a choice if he was
going to be my friend or not i was like
we're doing this i like to koala on the
eucalyptus tree myself
and so we met on the red carpet and then
it's been 15 years since we've been
great friends forever we always work
together and i will tell you this nikki
and i are hosting the ambi awards which
is like the podcast academy awards this
year
very exciting
and
i don't know if you know this but nikki
won podcast of the year last year for
dying for sex
i know it was such an honor i was so
blown away by it that must have felt
good it felt amazing and for many
reasons obviously just to be honored for
storytelling and and also the podcast
was about something very very near and
dear to my heart so you're going to love
that you i hope you listen because it's
called dying for sex and it's about
my best friend molly and she was
diagnosed with stage four breast cancer
so she decided to do something really
bold so she left her marriage of 15
years and decided to go on a sexual
journey and finding herself so it's not
just about sex it's about love it's
about friendship and it's about finding
what you want to do with the time you
have left wow i i have to admit that's
um
that setting that tone is extraordinary
thank you my friend look at my friends
they're so amazing
too right
well speaking of stories nikki actually
would you be kind enough to tell our
next story i would love to i'm excited
about the story of course everything's
wedding related so if you're thinking of
popping the question there's a brand new
way to do it my friends the new york
times reports that people have moved on
from the flash mob to the proposal party
the proposal party is a secret gathering
of your friends and your family
where your beloved is under a false
pretense of why they're coming to the
party and then you surprise them with a
proposal doesn't that sound fabulous
well
wait no
this gives me anxiety
um um i've been pressured into things in
my life and i think when a lot of people
are there watching you feel obliged
to not let the moment go wrong and then
before you know it you might find
yourself in a situation that you are not
certain about but feel you know
pressured into because there's a whole
group of people staring at you oh that
you're going to say yes because grandma
and helen are staring at you you're just
exactly really i never thought of oh god
i never thought about that you're right
and i for some reason i'm only thinking
about that
it makes my head tingle yeah you know i
thought it's kind of differently though
okay you give give the devil's advocate
well i just thought like when i proposed
to ellie it was the height of the
pandemic and we did it on zoom and i
surprised well i told we had to zoom
happy hour with friends but i had this
one nikki boyer
she navigated and hosted the whole thing
and i have to say before that happened i
would have rolled my eyes at something
like that but then once i got to host
the party and invite the family members
in and we all got to talk beforehand and
then welly and ross popped up on the
screen and then it sort of all unfolded
so beautifully i was like oh this is
magical
all right
next up you know we like to tackle the
really important questions at this desk
questions like are tall skinny dudes the
best cuddlers
well a writer at instyle investigated
this story and so many people are hot to
trot for tall noodle men like david said
machine gun kelly they like them and the
writer of the article herself loves a
cuddle with a good gumby-like man
it turns out there is no scientific
evidence that this is true i know but
there is science behind cuddling it's
good for you it increases your feel good
hormones and i know you two are two of
the most tactile people i know i'm very
affectionate i touched people by that i
shouldn't probably touch yeah i am way
too enthusiastic and way too grabby you
know who's someone i do know that i like
to cuddle
my best friend chicken
[Applause]
get in here
[Applause]
be curious
[Music]